son las ocho y veintinueve minutos de la
noche en Bogotá quito y Lima continuamos
en directo América edición nocturna Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
grupos de manifestantes incendiaron
pilas de basura y se enfrentaron a la
policía en París como parte de las
protestas luego de que la asamblea
nacional no aprobara dos mociones de
censura con lo que se mantiene en pie la
decisión del gobierno francés de aprobar
la controversial reforma a las pensiones
sin debate legislativo
desde Moscú el presidente chino dio
total respaldo a su homólogo ruso
Vladimir Putin en su incursión en
Ucrania el mandatario chino aseguró que
su país tomará una posición justa de
objetiva el jefe de estado ruso Indicó
que estudiará la propuesta de paz
presentada por Beijing
el mundo tiene que recortar sus
emisiones contaminantes a la mitad antes
de 2030 esto es lo que alerta al grupo
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático en su más reciente
informe en el que añade que la subida
del nivel del mar durante milenios ya es
inevitable
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos en la capital francesa donde
hasta entrada de la noche continuaron
las protestas de ciudadanos luego de que
dos mociones de confianza contra el
gobierno de la primera ministra
Elizabeth bosnio se hundieran en la
asamblea nacional grupos de ciudadanos
se enfrentaron a las autoridades que
buscaban disolver las manifestaciones e
incendiaron pilas de basura esto en
medio de la huelga de recolectores de
desechos que inició A mediados de la
semana pasada y ha causado
perturbaciones en la ciudad ampliamos
los detalles en el informe
decimoquinto día de huelga y las basuras
siguen transformando las calles de París
en pasillos estrechos y malolientes en
París a pesar de las adquisiciones las
recolecciones siguen atrasadas y las
montañas de basura obligan a los
comerciantes a organizarse para reducir
las molestias como pueden escondemos las
basuras porque es asqueroso para los
clientes
algunos tomaron iniciativas como este
farmacéutico el miércoles pasado llamó a
una sociedad de recolección privada
porque la puerta de su tienda estaba
llena de basura
era más o menos de dos metros de altura
hasta aquí
un servicio que le costó alrededor de
500 euros y dice que los pagaría otra
vez si es necesario
y todos los días Esperamos que los
recolectores pasen y si no llegan
Tendremos que llamar otra vez a esta
sociedad privada y una tercera vez y así
sucesivamente desde el jueves algunos
recolectores Se recibieron órdenes de
adelantar las labores pero las colectas
siguen siendo limitadas algunas
incineradoras siguen bloqueadas como la
de Y si le molino esta mañana solo un
camión podía entrar cada 15 minutos
este conductor tuvo que irse sin haber
podido Descargar
ahora dónde va
regreso al garaje de el camión lleno
algunos vehículos salieron del depósito
pero regresaron sin recoger ni un solo
residuo
se necesitarían tres días completos de
recolección a toda velocidad para lograr
evacuar las más de 9000 toneladas de
basura que se acumulan en las calles de
París esta mañana en algunas ciudades
como León varios recolectores también se
unieron al movimiento
tras más de cuatro horas Finalizó el
primer día de encuentro entre los
presidentes de Rusia Vladimir Putin y
china reunidos en Moscú el líder del
kremlin aseguró que analizó el plan de
paz en Ucrania elaborado por China y le
dijo Así que podrían discutirlo la
reunión se retoma mañana martes
Washington reaccionó diciendo que el
mundo no debe dejarse engañar por la
propuesta la Israel tiene los detalles
un viaje a Rusia por la paz según
durante esta visita oficial de tres días
el presidente chino y su homólogo ruso
Vladimir Putin plantean la eventual
resolución del conflicto en Ucrania como
eje central el 24 de febrero Beijing
propuso un plan en 12 puntos para
alcanzar la paz y este lunes Rusia se
dijo abierta a dialogar
sin duda debatiremos todas estas
cuestiones
incluida sus iniciativas que tratamos
con respeto Por supuesto
a lo largo del conflicto china ha dicho
que deben respetarse la soberanía y la
integridad territorial de todos sus
países y pidió la protección de los
civiles en su propuesta sin embargo
sigue sin estar claros y simpatiza con
las reivindicaciones de Moscú hemos
visto que el plan de paz pide
efectivamente un alto al fuego que
garantizaría a Rusia la ocupación de
grandes franjas de territorio ucraniano
con más tierra de Ucrania de la que
tenían al entrar en la guerra
Estados Unidos ha advertido que no
suministre armas a Rusia algo que ha
planteado como una posibilidad y hoy
expresó nuevamente su escepticismo ante
la propuesta china el mundo no debe
dejarse engañar por ningún movimiento
táctico de Rusia apoyada por China o
cualquier otro país para congelar la
guerra en sus propios términos
posturas similares han adoptado la
reunión Europea y la otan subrayando que
china se ha abstenido de condenar a
Rusia por su invasión de su lado quiebre
afirmó el lunes que la rendición o La
retirada de las tropas rusas del
territorio Ucrania no tienen que ser
condiciones previas para que pueda
aplicarse el plan de paz chino las
directivas de Amazon anunciaron el
recorte de 9000 empleos Durante los
próximos meses debido a la incertidumbre
económica actual argumentaron que es una
decisión que beneficiará a la compañía
en el futuro esta medida se suma a otro
despido masivo que dejó a 18.000
personas sin empleo Durante los últimos
meses veamos más en el informe de Andrés
trigueño
Amazon una nueva Ronda de despidos
masivos a empleados así lo dio a conocer
mediante un comunicado Andy yasi
director general de la compañía Durante
las próximas semanas 9000 trabajadores
se verán afectados sumándose a los
despidos que comenzaron en noviembre del
año pasado y que se extendieron hasta
enero dejando sin empleo a un total de
27.000 personas durante varios años
previos a este la mayoría de nuestros
negocios agregaron una cantidad
significativa de empleados sin embargo
dada la incertidumbre económica en la
que vivimos y la incertidumbre que
existe en el futuro cercano hemos optado
por ser más eficientes en nuestros
costos y personal ya así aseguró que las
áreas que se verán más afectadas serán
los servicios web el reclutamiento
humano publicidad y la aplicación de
streaming tweets la cual no ha dado los
resultados esperados a la compañía
Igualmente aseguró que durante la
pandemia se crearon nuevos empleos que
ahora ya no son necesarios Porque el
repunte de la demanda cayó a medida que
se relajaron las restricciones Por lo
cual también se produce el anuncio
Amazon la segunda empresa con mayor
número de empleados de Estados Unidos
con 1.5 millones de trabajadores
solamente por detrás de los
supermercados Walmart así el gigante del
comercio electrónico se suma a otras
empresas tecnológicas como Microsoft y
meta la matriz de Facebook la cual dijo
que eliminaría 10.000 empleos este año
luego de acabar con 11.000 puestos en
total el sector tecnológico ha despedido
a más de 200.000 personas Amazon ha
dicho que sus ganancias operativas
Pueden seguir cayendo en los próximos
meses debido a las condiciones
económicas a nivel global mientras que
sus acciones cayeron un 1.4% luego del
anuncio
vamos a Bolivia porque el país se
enfrenta un fuerte brote de dengue desde
el inicio de 2023 alrededor de 50
personas han perdido la vida por la
enfermedad y se han confirmado
15,645 casos en los departamentos de
Santa Cruz Benny tarija la paz
Cochabamba chuquisaca y Pando las
autoridades indican que la incidencia ha
disminuido pero piden mantenerse alerta
para analizar esta problemática
conectamos con Francis Hinojosa les
asesor en salud pública de la Federación
de sindicatos de ramas médicas de salud
pública en Bolivia bienvenido France 24
el gobierno resalta la importancia en la
disminución de estas cifras en la última
semana Pero es adecuado bajar la guardia
gracias buenas noches de ninguna manera
porque también es una lección aprendida
no es la primera epidemia ya el 2009 nos
había pasado
quizás en una mayor cantidad inclusive
pero fue la población que reaccionó Y
que todos trabajamos para poder combatir
esta epidemia y no dejarlo otra vez que
ocurra lo mismo no bueno Y cómo está el
sistema sanitario en estos momentos es
decir hay la infraestructura suficiente
para atender los casos
Lamentablemente creo que no hay
un poco los países que pueden tener ese
privilegio estamos rebasados con la
cantidad de casos y especialmente la
cantidad de muertes y en los en nuestros
niños nos faltan los recursos humanos si
bien hay algo de infraestructura pero
lamentablemente los recursos humanos no
están disponibles y no podemos habilitar
camas como quisiéramos entonces nuestro
sistema de estado completamente
colapsado especialmente en tercer nivel
segundo nivel y tenemos que lamentar
cuarenta y siete muertes a nivel
nacional Bueno y cómo se controla este
tipo de brote Qué acciones lleva a cabo
el ejecutivo y que otras estrategias Se
podrían implementar
la principal estrategia Es que la
población esté consciente de que más
allá de la fumigación necesitamos
destruir criadero no que haya una
conciencia de poder
limpiarón trasero como decimos acá poder
destruir estos criaderos y tener una
cultura
en ese sentido también el mismo sistema
pues no esperamos que
podamos lograr coordinar entre los
gobiernos el gobierno central gobierno
departamental gobierno municipal que en
los últimos meses de esta pandemia pues
hemos visto que lastimosamente no hubo
ese nivel de coordinación y creo que eso
ha afectado un poco también creo que
esas son las lecciones aprendidas y
esperemos que en el futuro podamos
mejorarlo
Muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
Gracias muy amable en otras noticias la
situación climática es crítica pero
Todavía existen soluciones y se toma una
acción global inmediata Esto es lo que
asegura el grupo intergubernamental de
expertos sobre el cambio climático de la
ONU que publicó las conclusiones de su
sexto informe aprobado por 195 países el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez dijo que el texto
supone una guía de supervivencia para la
humanidad Gabriel colchón nos cuenta más
la crisis climática es una bomba de
tiempo y el tiempo se acaba en su sexto
informe el grupo intergubernamental de
expertos sobre el cambio climático
advirtió que las medidas tomadas para
luchar contra el calentamiento global
son insuficientes y que nos acercamos a
un punto de inflexión que llevaría a
graves impactos y reversibles
la humanidad está sobre un hielo delgado
y ese hielo se está derritiendo
rápidamente como detalla el informe de
hoy del panel intergubernamental sobre
el cambio climático los humanos son
responsables de Prácticamente todo el
calentamiento global en los últimos 200
años
la tasa de aumento de la temperatura en
el último medio siglo es la más alta en
2000 años la concentración de dióxido de
carbono está en su punto más alto en al
menos dos millones de años la bomba del
tiempo climática está en marcha
sin embargo los expertos informan que
existe la posibilidad de garantizar un
futuro habitable y sostenible a todos
siempre y cuando haya una acción
inmediata la ventana de oportunidad se
cierra rápidamente por lo que piden que
las emisiones de carbono sean reducidas
a la mitad para 2030 la ONU insta a los
países desarrollados a comprometerse con
una adelanto de los objetivos en materia
de neutralidad de emisiones pasando del
objetivo fijado en 2050 a 2040
el límite de 1.5 grados Celsius es
alcanzable pero ahora falta un salto
cuántico en la acción climática este
informe es un toque de atención para que
todos los países todos los sectores y
todos los plazos aceleren masivamente
sus esfuerzos por el clima en resumen
nuestro mundo necesita una acción
climática en todos los frentes todo en
todas partes al mismo tiempo
el mundo experimenta actualmente 1,1
grados de calentamiento En comparación
con la temperatura de la era
preindustrial el aumento de los
fenómenos extremos como de calor
inundaciones o ciclones Ya se está
produciendo en todos los continentes si
el mundo continúa por la vía actual el
calentamiento sería de más de 3 grados
para finales de siglo con consecuencias
difíciles de predecir así llegamos al
final de esta misión de directo América
aquí en France 24 a ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega a
malbecnotman con toda la información del
continente africano en África 7 días
feliz noche para todos
[Música]